a medium security prison for a high risk
offender 42 year old parisio Duarte
Herrera escaping the southern desert
Correctional Center Friday after the
Nevada Department of Corrections first
implied it was actually this past
Tuesday he's now one of over 20 who've
escaped from the prison still
unaccounted for since the 70s the
sources telling eight news now
investigators that battery acid helped
erode his cell's window coverings
creating the space to climb out leaving
a cardboard dummy in his place the
Escape over two barbed wire fences while
wearing a jacket he sewed together in a
prison class they knew that something
like this was probably going to happen
Paul lunkwinds is the president of the
Fraternal Order of Police a union
representing Nevada correctional
officers a lack of oversight maintenance
and Staffing is what he says made this
Escape possible their Staffing is
typically two per unit at Southern
desert but they rarely if ever have two
officers in one year one or two officers
to monitor up to around 200 inmates and
what about the guard towers outside and
they had no one up there until yesterday
after this happened now I'm being told
they're Manning all the towers they
don't have the staff to put in there
because they can't retain staff because
they treat them so poorly